the new release of resident evil 4 and
vr on meta quest 2 is exactly the game
we need right now
if you're feeling cooped up pop on your
metaquest too and experience a quaint
spanish village
get some exercise
and get up close and personal with the
locals
whether you know every secret corner of
the original game or you've never even
heard of the series this game is a
must-have the vr integration and full
360 degree sound upgrade turns one of
the greatest games ever made into an
immersive masterpiece also the
conversion made chasing chickens around
villages even more fun than it used to
be
when it was originally released in 2005
resident evil 4 altered the way we
experienced horror in action games by
changing the viewpoint from which we saw
them the over-the-shoulder camera angle
that the game introduced has since
become the standard for the third person
action and shooter genre and now one of
the most significant games in history is
getting its most significant update
armature studios and meta have teamed up
to fully port and update the game into a
first person nightmare you experience
from behind the eyes of leon kennedy
himself the unfortunate raccoon city cop
turned government agent who's called on
by his country to save the president's
daughter from a cult whoever this group
is they sure picked the wrong girl to
kidnap exclusively on metaquest 2 you
get back into all the gennado's killing
fun you remember but this time as you
battle through the infected legions you
will actually be able to move your body
to dodge those pitch forks
slash with your knife and pull your
shotgun off your back to blast lost
plagueis right out of those sorry
so-and-so's
the world of re4 feels more real than
ever as you use your metaquest touch
controllers to pull levers use keys push
open doors and of course take careful
aim to conserve your precious ammo if
you've never had the chance to shoot
mind control parasite infected villagers
calling you an imbecile in spanish you
definitely should get into resident evil
4 and vr on metaquest 2. the story
immediately immerses you i'm under the
president's order to rescue you so it's
easy to get into the role of a special
agent trying to save the president's
daughter the gameplay is fun and
challenging with a creepy retro feeling
art style that increases the anxiety and
tension you feel as you push open each
door using your actual hands resident
evil 4 was never the most terrifying
game in the series but adding the
immersion of the first person vr makes
it so much scarier you can almost feel
the wind from the gonados axes as they
whizz past your head and you never
realize just how huge your gigantes
actually are until you have to crane
your neck to see their eyes as you stand
toed a giant toe with one the metaquest
ii's high per-eye resolution really
helps see the gross details that
armature painstakingly repainted and
uprest to bring the original re4 assets
into a 360 degree world and the audio
has been reworked to create a 3d spatial
soundscape that makes you whip your head
around and panic at every creaky board
but that instinct will keep you alive as
the infected will make noise from the
direction they are attacking from
armature built the game around the
original building blocks of re4 trying
to preserve as much of the gameplay
style and feel as possible while
upgrading the game to vr the story is
the same the cut scenes are in their
original format character animations
have stayed the same other than being
converted to the latest unreal engine
and altered to be experienced from vr
the world itself is based on the exact
same geometry as the original version
meaning those little tricks you use to
outsmart the gennados might still work
exactly like they used to the quicktime
events have been updated to work with
the metaquest touch controllers so
instead of pressing a sequence of
buttons you'll need to use them to match
the movements on screen and using them
to arrange the guns and herbs in your
trusty old attache case in the menu
makes it a physical puzzle rather than a
chore like it used to be in order to
make the game accessible to any horror
fan even those who are prone to motion
sickness armature added an awesome array
of view and control customization some
options include changing your movement
style limiting your peripheral vision
and the ability to play while sitting or
standing most importantly though they
made changes to the president's daughter
ashley so she doesn't constantly die on
you while you try to escort her through
teeming masses of sick and grumpy
spanish villagers before you get into it
here are some tips for my own rescue
attempt into 1998 spain make sure you
test out your view and movement style
options for a bit before you get going
the snap versus smooth modes for looking
around really changed my experience try
out each gun in the shooting range
before playing you'll learn how the gun
play works increase your accuracy and
you can even earn trophies you can hold
your knife in one hand and a one-handed
gun in the other so taking out infected
is way more fun than it used to be but
it's also now kind of a physical combo
if you're attacked by a mob shoot the
closest one in the head to stun them and
then slash them with your knife using
your gun to hold off the others it can
get pretty engrossing to fight mobs of
villagers coming at you like cattle so
remember not to just hang around and
wait for them to come at you this is a
3d world now so move and dodge while
holding them off
resident evil 4 on meta quest 2 is all
around a great game armature respected
the original experience while upgrading
it enough to make it a vr conversion
that rivals any other aaa game to come
out this year the menus control options
gun play and uprest art all blend
together into a must-have for any
metaquest 2 owner and it's definitely a
reason to get one if you don't already
have one resident evil 4 released
exclusively on meta quest 2. if you want
to know more go to oculus.com forward
slash quest 2.